foreign
[Music]
yes it's another day another beautiful
day uh it is Wednesday for the patreon
people and it is Thursday for the people
who watch us on YouTube and I just want
to say dude uh
uh I am really uh happy I am recording
this a few days a week before because I
had to because I wouldn't be here for
the Monday when I normally recorded
babies and I am doing
um what do you call it uh so so I would
normally come and I'm gonna do the intro
but I would normally come and be like
hey guys San Antonio New Orleans and uh
Sugarland was amazing but I didn't do it
yet so dude this is the future episode
of congratulations
[Music]
we are in the future
we are in the future what I I guess I
guess what it means is we're in the past
is actually what I mean we are in the
past because I did this episode let's
see uh what is it Wednesday Thursday
about a week ago
bottle and remember and then that guy
killed someone and then went to jail for
like six years I I don't know the Bobby
Schmurda you go to jail for like if
you're a rapper you go to jail for like
six years if you kill someone I don't
really understand what that is but hey
God bless and also uh he did his time
and then he came out and everyone's like
[__] yeah free Bobby Shmurda he's out
and he's out dude and now he's just
getting [__] millions of followers
and millions of likes and the guy
[__] killed someone and you know what
dude
I don't know man it's it's very weird
but it's also you know it's how it is so
that's what's up my baby and uh so he's
out there he's gonna make some [__]
bangers now dude I mean honestly jail
for hip hoppers is like the [__]
incredible when [__] shine gets out
forget it when shine gets out oh
remember that song oh
oh so bad um
remember when [__] he was like yeah I
I took the rap for for Diddy or whatever
and now Diddy's got like a quadrillion
million dollars and shine's just sitting
in jail is he still in jail I don't know
but uh and then like he he took the rap
or whatever I you know I don't know what
it was but
he shot somebody for Diddy hey dude no
you know how people are like stop
snitching
or don't snitch you know how like Mafia
guys are like yeah I went to jail for
[__] nine years because I wouldn't
I'm no I'm no rat dude that's the movies
man
I see someone do something and the cops
come to me hey it was that guy Billy
whoa
um so yes I will be in New York City New
York City
February 18th I'll be on Rhode Island
February 17th I think that's sold out
I'll be in Chicago that's sold out I
will be in uh where else am I gonna be
by the ways
uh let me look it up
uh let me look it up I will be in uh
Kansas City Missouri Springfield that's
sold out Tulsa Oklahoma Midland Texas
your boy doesn't really sell tickets in
Midland what the [__] a figure but it's
all good dude because he keeps the seats
warm in other spots
uh like Austin Texas where he added
another one oh Jesus Christ Austin Texas
uh Milwaukee Minneapolis I'm gonna do it
there added another show at State
Theater Columbus Ohio Cincy Cincinnati
Boise and Salt Lake City Utah add more I
told my guess what I told my my tour guy
I said hey guy are we taking summer off
and he says yeah summer is not really a
great place to it's not a good time for
a comedian to tour because there's a lot
of festivals people want to be outside I
go like this hey dude
book more
that's what I did and I did that
strictly I strictly said book more
because I go like this man I got a lot
of [__] haters out there and
then I go like this damn Matt I'm on the
road and I go like this
hmm
I process it
and then I think about what the [__]
would Tupac do what would Tupac do
doublet I'm Gonna Keep doubling it until
they kill me so I go like this
summertime
book more
so now now I book more now I book more
that's what happens I'm on my new [__]
dude book more
so I [__] your [__]
so [__] how I did it but
um yeah dude I'm gonna come to different
places dude
extra paper scoop that up like that's
just how it's gonna be from now on
keep screaming absolutely scoop extra
paper miles done that's what it's gonna
be dude
piles done so
that's the best impression I Do by the
way biles done
um yeah dude I just it's like you know I
got two dates coming up in May I'm
having a baby in April so it's like what
more you want from me dude I'm gonna be
a guy with two kids
[Laughter]
dude that's hilarious like And subscribe
you know what I mean it's for my family
so
um but yeah we have a good time I'm
gonna be in all those cities and I can't
wait dude the hour is really coming
along dude can't wait to be in New York
I can't wait to be in New York you're
gonna see a lot of family I'm gonna see
a lot of friends that I want to and some
extended family I don't and uh because
you know he's a city boy what can he say
he's a city boy he's not a city boy you
grew up in Montclair New Jersey but his
dad was a city boy
his dad was a city boy he grew up in
Queens that's he grew up in Mass with
Queens right and his dad's name was bam
right
my grandpa's name was Vincent they
called him bam because when he was
younger he was skinny like a bamboo sick
he then got a belly and it's all good
and my dad always says I remind me of
him and it's beautiful and I love him
but uh I had a grandpa bam and a Grandma
Dottie eh
Maspeth Queens New York
um Italian
um
so yeah dude and um that's how we do it
we're going to double it we're going to
keep doubling it until it kill me
uh Tupac was great man remember when
lausanne said he didn't like Tupac
because his music wasn't good and I was
just like you know it's okay I get it
man hip-hop has changed right it really
has changed it really has changed
um
and it's crazy actually how much to be
brutally honest with you guys
um
actually there was a bunch of stuff a
bunch of topics can you send me the
thing oh you have it right here is here
oh it's a bookmark you got the bookmark
dude
um hip-hop has really changed I don't
understand look at Tupac on the [__]
scooter that's so dope dude
um
I don't know if
I already talked about pickleball right
yeah I did
um I don't know if hip-hop is
it's crazy how bad it is now okay now I
don't mean all hip-hop there's good
people out there that are [__] doing
good hip-hop and like Nas is still
killing it but it's like also
everything is auto-tune I don't know man
it was a T-Pain that [__] ruined at
all his [__] kind of banged though that
I didn't know this but I was talking to
a buddy of mine oh it was my cameraman
29 years old and his name is Sam and he
was like dude remember how [__] big
T-Pain was and he's like that was my
childhood and I'm like no I don't know
T-Pain to me was when I was
32 and I'm like what is this dude
you know he said Mansion in Wisconsin
and I go
[Music]
what do you say with mansion with what
Wisconsin
oh the gunk
I don't even wear shoes that make that
noise but and you know I did I did then
and um
yeah dude I just can't do it
are you [__] kidding me shine is out
and a politician
on the of course it is news
Shine the rapper that [__] look at
this
Jamal Michael Barrow best known as Jason
by shine is a
Belizean rapper and politician he's
leader of the opposition in the police
House of Representatives and the leader
of the Belize United Democratic party
Barrow was for those who don't know who
shine is he was a guy on Bad Boy Records
that sounded like Biggie and he was like
a guy that rapped and and did he was
like the person that found the next
Biggie and then they had a short-lived
career had one song that went and then
who shot somebody and then went to jail
um
if you give me on the verge of release
he's like uh yeah here we go on the
evening of December 27 1999 he went to a
nightclub with uh his mentor label boss
P Diddy Sean Combs then and then
girlfriend Jennifer Lopez an argument
broke out in the club between Cubs and
another man guns were drawn shots fired
and three by centers were injured on
June 2001 he was convicted of assault
and sentenced to 10 years of prison his
2000 debut album was never less a
success and he continued to record music
while incarcerated dude how are rappers
doing that you always hear about rappers
that are like like who's got the [__]
how are you recording music incarcerated
I feel like even if You Freestyle too
loud the guards like yo shut the [__] up
and these guys are coming out with
full-fledged EPS or LPS or [__]
honestly
how do you do that
oh look at this while serving his prison
said that shine became interested in
Judaism
became reserving practice he's a Jew
is that what it is this what I'm reading
right
Orthodox he's an orthodox Jew dude
I mean he practically was doing it
speaking Hebrew in that song
his new song
oh bring chili boy Lloyd Lloyd
gonna get canceled again after he was
released in prison in 2009 dude he did
nine years bro
holy [__] [__] man
um he spent time he's studying the Torah
up to 12 hours a day dude
holy [__]
he returned to Belize in 2013 and was
appointed the Belize music and good good
God bless man the guy turned his life
around
didn't kill someone injured someone and
went to jail for nine years [__]
do you remember that song though do
people remember that song
ah
ah shine
bad boys this was the song I Gotta play
a little bit because I don't want to get
demonetized but
here we go
not it things like chicken great pissed
dude I already I signed in the other day
dude it's so annoying
[Music]
that part
that song
touch the hot stove um so uh yeah dude
that's amazing that he's a politician
that's the thing that you can do if you
[__] up big time how crazy is it that if
you [__] up big time you can just run a
country
it's like you can't get a job
at like a [__] agency in Hollywood or
you can't get a job at like some big
Corporation but you can run a country
all these [__] dude
I swear to God pretty soon the country
is going to be run by honestly
uh like uh [__]
well I [__] it up can't even think of
two people have one but I don't want to
do the one without the other
Jeremy Piven and Caitlyn Jenner she
killed someone
um so
yeah dude I I just uh
so anyway I was cooking eggs earlier
with Calvin
um
and uh it was a beautiful thing
I woke up and he ate four muffins my
nanny gave him four muffins
uh four little muffins you know and they
count that my wife counts that as uh
breakfast by the way when I count that
as a dessert but so I'm like did he eat
well and she's like yeah he ate
breakfast and then later on I'll find
out that he just ate like four muffins
and some gummy bears which is fine I
mean he needs calories and you know his
thing is eating a lot of people's dad
you know a lot of people's sons and and
[__] and daughters or children whatever
they have like the thing where it's like
they're not smart or they're not you
know
active or they're not this mine is my
son is just like oh dude you think I
need to eat [__] off oh you think I need
to eat huh no I don't and he'll just
hold out for those Gummy Bears or
Jujubes or some [__] dude the other day
he was he came up to me and he had these
gummy bears and he I don't even know by
the way he gets in the pantry come I
hear this is what this is why I know I'm
[__] by the way this is why I know
it's gonna be a tough day for my son
eating I'm watching TV and I hear from
the kitchen
and I'm like
I'm [__]
he comes up with a little bag of Gummy
Bears which by the way I don't know who
got them I said to my wife I said where
do we get these and she says I have no
idea oh they just appear
that's how good uh General Mills is
or whatever whoever is Little Debbie
snacks I don't know
and um
and he says can I have this Dad and I
said buddy you didn't eat
breakfast I I I don't know if you should
eat these you can have a few because I'm
sucker right sucker Central and and my
son goes like this
more and more and more and more and more
and more I want 10 of them
and I laughed dude and I said Calvin you
have to eat actual food and he starts
crying and I [__] don't give it to
him I was like we can't eat these dude
we gotta eat an actual real food Okay so
then he grabs the bag brings it over to
my nanny and or his Nanny and says
can I have these and she's like your dad
said you need to eat real food that's a
dessert food you need to eat real food
and then
he cries brings them back puts them down
then
[__]
I go to do uh Lifeline the other podcast
here on super good on the super good
Channel
I come back my parents are over they
said they were gonna come over they're
gonna come over to hang out with Calvin
okay I'm chilling for a little bit
my son is in the other room and my my
grandpa his grandpa pop pop is in the
other room Calvin comes back eating the
[__] gummy bears and I say what
where'd you get those and he says pop
pop my dad comes in and my mom's like oh
papa is a sucker
I guess that's what grandpas are
supposed to do and it was cute
so then today I was like I gotta get
some actual real food in them and I made
we made eggs we made eggs and it was a
beautiful thing he loved stirring it and
then I was giving him eggs and he goes
like and I and I said you like them we
made good eggs huh and he said yes we
did and it was so freaking cute dude
um
let's do this because this is a thing
and I actually can't believe it to be
brutally honest with you guys slap
League
I don't at Wells Fargo this is damn it
God I need to sign in
we we look dude I signed in okay got him
dripped out with the kiss [__] you can't
even see it but it's got like beautiful
different colors we love we love kit but
this is the ABC
thing
guys I want to talk to you about pure
Spectrum this is a product that I use
that is great pure Spectrum CBD and you
can go get 15 look a lot of CBD
companies they [__] they talk about
[__] and they say it works whatever I am
telling you I started using this thing
and it works my anxiety has kept at Bay
um I'm just generally overall happier
and I don't mean like tralala happy I
just mean I could deal with [__] I'm
less of a curmudgeon I don't snap you
know it just between therapy and using
the CBD it helps it's called Pure
Spectrum go to the pure Spectrum website
and type in congrats you will get 15 off
the pure Spectrum products it is uh it
is great man and I'm using it I'm you
know I I partner with this company and
I'm using them because it really helps
um so I got them it originally was 10
off
um I got them to do 15 off for the
listeners of congratulations so go try
it dude just try taking the CBD gummies
I like the gummies you can do the
droppers too I do the droppers
um but it helps your overall mood and
anxiety and at least for me it just
makes me able to like do things like be
at weddings and not be like I gotta
leave this wedding I'm having fun at
weddings now
um it really helps man so go and uh go
to that pure Spectrum website and type
in code congrats and you will get 15 off
it helps thank you very much guys back
to the show
[Music]
nope nope I did a commercial for Burger
King once uh all right cool
dude two chicks whoa
they're kind of hot oh my God that's
brutal no
what a slap I'm done after that
what's Logan Paul doing this wow that's
crazy
laughing
why are they laughing
Governor what'd you think of that I
thank God it wasn't me that got slapped
oh my god dude dude what is this country
coming to
hot women slapping each other
and then then I'm like well this is just
pinnacle
idiocracy and then
date and then you find out Arnold
Schwarzenegger's there
it's South Park you know
this is just absolutely I'm glad I
wasn't only receiving end of The Slap
[Laughter]
running his words together so much dude
I'm glad that wasn't receiving Into The
Slap
she's got this form nailed down hey you
know they're slapping each other dude
the chin is tough
oh the way she's revving up
oh didn't didn't make it hit the top of
her head shot in my opinion oh wow
oh no big dudes
look at the [__] the way they're
hopping up and down
this is a league
sfc
of course dude the most hardcore dudes
from look at how big these guys are hey
guys just wrestle
the two most [__] hardcore dude
Slovakia holy [__]
here we go all right governor
a weight lifter he have an advantage
being a power lifter and slap fighter
Arnold Schwarzenegger got paid two
million dollars
who's the toughest who can take it right
here we go we'll go first
punched him oh oh he almost fell oh
I've seen him wobble a little bit he did
wobble
this is just understand a word you're
saying horrible but the folks do
the judges saw something
I mean
let's see this checking his chin you
cannot drop your chin to obstruct that
jaw okay Jesus Christ this is horrible
dude
done he's gone
oh
dude this is horrible man
why are they doing it
dude what
this is the thing too these guys don't
get paid you know like they're not
getting paid this is slap Fighting
Championship
this is so so so bad
always is there more people getting
knocked out wait there's there's let's
watch this one this is a
this is at the end
oh my
God
[__] dude he's so angry looking
Piccolo also known as Mr Clean because
he slaps the cleanest
dark
says it on the card
ah dude how mad would you do you get
when you get hit every time I feel like
to UFC dude when you get smacked and
that sting bro
holy freaking [__] dude
wow
this is just stupid
yeah dude Tom Brady's [__] dude he
look uh
I
understand
Tom Brady's like 45 or something right
he's a little older than me
um he looks great he's in great shape
Tom Brady I don't like people that
retire more than once I I don't like
when people retire when he wants Jay-Z
did it when he was 33 and then [__]
kept doing United got bigger than ever I
don't like when people retire or or and
then decide to come out of it there's no
coming out of retirement for me for me
you retire you're done I don't watch you
anymore dude I I don't I don't watch the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers I don't watch the
Jay-Z you know after the [__] It's A
Hard Knock Life I was I was done because
he retired dude he said it on David
Letterman or whatever the [__] and uh I
don't you know
props to you for retire I think Tom
here's the deal you want to go out on
top I get it but you also want to keep
playing the game but here's the deal too
is that Tom Brady is so rich none dude
if I make
whatever he got 300 500 million dollars
hey
for real dude oh
okay
I'm done
and that's not to say I I do stand up
for money you know I I do it because I
love it but also money
I'm on it
you need to know the value of your worth
if you're not gonna pay me for the
[__] show not doing it even though
love it would do it for free not gonna
right Tom Brady would play football for
free but also not gonna huh you know
what I'm saying once you establish your
worth pay me it I want the Rex you're
not gonna give it to me bye he made 500
million dollars bye dude the guy's got
to deal with Skechers or some [__]
probably you know
and also Cheerios and Wheaties whatever
the [__] he's got you know how many
endorsements these guys probably got
something for Icy Hot he's got some real
estate invest development you know he's
got money in the probably he's got dude
the guys when you got 500 million
dollars also you definitely belong in
jail because he did something [__] up
and you don't even know by the way your
business manager is like ah [__] it
yeah you know I didn't mean to I put
money into the sex trade industry in
China I'm sorry I [__] up dude I know
I [__] up dude but this is my now I
yeah I know dude you were playing for
the Buccaneers you would have known if
you if you listen to Giselle and you
quit you probably would have caught a
card that we were cooking the books but
you didn't now you gotta go jail sorry
dude
um
so yeah dude I you know retire once and
then that's it if I retire that's it
dude
don't come see me again if I do another
show
you gotta have another career I'm not
into it
um but you know God bless Tom Brady I
hope he repatch your [__] up with
Giselle I like those couples man I don't
like when people break up it makes me
sad that was the All-American Brazilian
couple man
Giselle huh wow just I thought that Tom
Brady makes a crazy more amount of money
than Giselle Google it dude giselle's
worth if you get that supermodel money
I'm talking about that upper echelon
supermodel money like the top 12
supermodel monies dude when you put your
when you put when you start modeling for
not just swimwear and [__] body [__]
and Gucci when you start modeling for
[__] cream anything cream face skin
lotion
that's it dude the makeup industry
you're modeling for the makeup injury or
cream dude
you think Tom Brady makes money for
throwing a football
Giselle comes in goes like this what
about what I rub all over my face
cream
um so Giselle you know I don't know if
Tom's gonna get half from the divorce
honestly if Tom Brady were really about
it he should [__] say yo I you owe me
half and then God how much pretty are
they how pretty are they
uh so yeah I don't know I I [__] more
power to Tom Brady for her time but just
that's it dude if you imagine being 45
and retired and just [__] be on boats
the rest of your life I don't even like
boats you just do it for the [__]
you know what I mean you just do it for
the [__] point of it
just sitting in big couches near
fireplaces just [__] God damn it hey
I'll start the documentary let me let me
ask you a question why why would you get
to a certain amount of money and I'm I
don't mean Tom Brady money I don't mean
Giselle money I mean more
I mean more than that
I mean uh who was the guy who did the
drug ring in uh Colombia the [__]
what's his name
the big guy
El Chapo when you get that money what is
it about that money
that makes you think and this has
happened to everyone who's got that kind
of money and that's a lot of that's
that's not that many people that's a lot
of money right I'm talking about like
kings and so and and and like princes
what is it about that money I'm talking
about
billions and billions not two billion
I'm talking about billions and billions
of dollars like 50 Bill even more a
hundred billion dollars like when you
have like we're talking about Stacks
dude
what is it about that money that makes
you go like this
I need a zoo
do you know what I'm talking about El
Chapo dude there's a huge hippo problem
in Colombia because El Chapo goes dude I
need some hippos then got killed and
then the hippos do what hippos do
[__] and eat and multiply dude there are
so many hippos including dude they
started out with a few hippos there's
like hundreds of hippos now hippos are
dangerous as [__] dude
and they're well what is it about the
billions of I
where you like need a white tie you need
a white tiger collection or you need
like dude these birds are only
if you
and now now it's like the the animal
purists are like well
now the hippos are here they shouldn't
be here but they are here so we gotta
kinda we gotta conserve we gotta make
sure that they're nah shoot them all ah
when it comes to animals I'm racist as
[__] animals go back to your [__]
country animals the animals where you're
born stay there because here's the deal
it becomes our problem wow I sound
racist it becomes our problem when you
now all of a sudden we got [__] like
Australia is [__] when you go to
Australia you ever hear the birds in
Australia they're just like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and there's a million of them and you're
just like at the park chilling with your
dog trying to throw a frisbee and the
birds are just
and the birds don't even they weren't
even born dude shoot them up but you
can't right it's too late
so my point is animals got to stay where
they are hey go back to Country Birds
that's me in Australia go back to your
[__] country
I don't even know if marsupials are
[__] uh
we're born there
right so it's like there are so many
animals in these countries that don't
belong there and they're [__] up the
ecosystem aren't they dude and you know
me dude I'm Mr Greenpeace
I care about the environment
I don't use hairspray
I cut the [__]
the six pack of cola shits I cut it and
I throw it away so the Dolphins don't
get killed remember when they did that
[__] when you were younger they'd be
like when you're young dude there was a
GI Joe I was like you know how they have
those [__] PSAs on the GI Joe be like
G.I Joe and some guy with a mustache and
a [__]
and a and a green like uh army suit
would just be like hey what are you
doing kid and the kid's like I'm just
throwing away the six-pack thing yeah
kid but you know that those can choke
fish what really yeah and then he goes
and saves a fish and takes it off so you
got to cut him really yeah look Indian
throws it away and winds up in a leg and
the fish just [__] swims past it and
it's like G.I Joe dude hey no
hey fish you get caught in a [__] six
pack of pib
in a in a six-pack carrier of what used
to be on pib
hey fish bye
GI Joe that's me out there hey kid what
you doing throwing away that thing make
sure to get it near the fish because if
they choke on it they deserve it let's
kill some flounders GI Joe
hey looks like some mackerels are gonna
die G.I Joe
my kid I'm a computer that [__] was so
funny from you bombs world but um
yeah dude that they never dealt with the
real hard-hitting issues it was like Hey
kid if you get sore put a Band-Aid on it
GI Joe some [__] guy in a you know in
a red helmet like not even a real
[__] like
what did GI Joe become it was like so
weird they made so many characters and
then all of a sudden they made [__] and
then they made uh uh Chuckles and he was
just like a guy with like cargo pants
and a Hawaiian shirt and I was like all
right dude he was my favorite one and
then I stopped I'm like you're not even
trying anymore I think you got the
[__] on vacation GI Joe remember
Chuckles from GI Joe he wore a [__]
Hawaiian shirt and cargo pants dude let
me let's find him Chuckles
he was my favorite GI Joe
look at him blonde hair Hawaiian shirt
dude
cargo pants and a gun
worst Soldier hey wasn't it about the
Army dude
that's so great
Hey kid relax be on vacation GI Joe
don't they never dealt with the real
[__] that was the thing
Hey kid don't stare at a bird too long
might Peck your eyes out G.I Joe dude
put me in there as a GI Joe
Hey kid careful who your friends are
they grow up and and stab you in the
back G.I Joe hey kids
don't be sleeping around raw GI Joe you
might get an SCP di Joe
what's an STD never mind G.I Joe dude
you're too young to know that never mind
I [__] GI Joe
Hey kid listen in school but not too
much because then you're a [__] G I Joe
wow I'm annoying dude
don't listen to your parents too much GI
Joe be an individual GI Joe
dude
so anyway yeah dude
um what was I talking about though the
[__] things that what was I talking
about before that I don't remember when
I go on tangents I need somebody to
literally just sit here I need a
stenographer for this podcast is what I
need who was I talking about some lady
oh you were talking about [__] cargo
pants
um
there's certain things in society and
just culture in America and the world
that
we're just done okay like it was a
tradition I always say this on this
podcast tradition
is [__] keep going keep growing keep
changing don't be all like hey but we've
been doing this for 50 years we got to
do it again no you don't because it
sucks because then once you solidify a
tradition anybody who infringes on that
tradition
irksia I want to live a non-irced life
this is why Wars start because of
religion religion what is religion
tradition you've infringe on the
tradition and all of a sudden you're
bombing [__] right how many
words start because of religion all of
them so there you go well a religion or
space not outer space space geography
uh we live here no no we want it no
that's a war other than that it's all
religion Okay so
tradition starts War we know that as
this cult and congratulations we get it
we do not have Traditions besides you
know the old one used to be sucking and
[__] in The Tall Grass we don't do
that anymore now we just build log
habits and share ideas okay I want to
deliver hedonistic lifestyle everyone
got mad at me for that okay fine so now
we're just building the Log Cabin
sitting in Tallgrass and sharing ideas
that's all good dude right okay
um
so here's something that we have of all
past and I say it now because it is
today and meaning it was last week
because you're listening because this
podcast is in the future we have to
predict but this was last week and it is
today what's what I'm saying hey
Groundhog's Day dude hey dude we're done
man hey Groundhog's Day you're not you
don't belong in this world in this world
where there is a slap fighting
competition League where Logan Paul
announces it and the governor
Arnold Schwarzenegger
is the vo guy
we don't need Groundhog's wait a minute
dude there's still people reporting on
Groundhog's Day
that Groundhog Day 2020 there's a
headline Punxsutawney Phil makes his
predictions from Gobbler's Knob hey
pack it up
hey
there's a slap fighting hey Elon ma hey
there's kinky porn you can download on
your phone in a Subway hey
robots are about to take over the world
hey
they threw a Tesla in outer space it was
just falling around hey
you know
Gobbler's Knob this is sexual
I mean I might as well call it Pokemon
makes his prediction for a [__]
bukaki face
makes a prediction from [__] all over
some titties
from [__] it all over some titties
Hill
dude hey dude Punxsutawney Phil makes
his prediction from uh [__] Hill
never get rimmed
um Groundhog Day dude this is so all
these dudes all old white dudes dude all
old white dudes
groundhog Club groundhog Club vice versa
why does it say it twice it says
groundhog Vice President Dan McKinley
and Dave gigliotti gigliotti entertain
the crowd no they don't while waiting
for Punxsutawney Phil the weather
prognostic groundhog you know talk about
words that should never go together
whether prognostic groundhog during the
137 celebration of Groundhog Day there
you go dude
this lasted more than five years what
[__] [__] are at this thing where
they're just like oh
um ooh can't wait to see if there's
gonna be more spring or whatever the
[__] it what is it winter
can't wait to see if can't wait to see
this little guy pop out of a hole or not
if there's gonna be more cold days are
you a witch
hi
there's iCloud
this is done dude
foreign
look at this
uh Gobbler's down and Punxsutawney this
is like a [__] place that what's her
name would uh would would uh JK
Rowling's would write a story about it's
not even a real play Thursday February
2nd Phil Phil's Handler said that the
groundhog has forecast six more weeks of
winter dude
and you gotta sit there as an adult with
no kids like you know if you're if I'm
there with Calvin right and I'm like oh
yeah it's gonna be more Winter by the
way Calvin already thinks that that's
horseshit and he can't even say
Punxsutawney he goes what
he knows
the fact that there's adults there with
no kids because there are and I don't
mean adults that never had kids I mean
you got to bring your kid there
otherwise if you're just standing there
alone not with your kid you're a [__]
lunatic dude
leave
someone wrote this article dude how
about that they didn't do it with their
kid
they put on glasses and actually sat
there I gotta do my [__] Punxsutawney
Phil uh article I can't guys I can't
come out sorry dude you know what
happened yeah no [__] they they were ah
[__] looking at his phone God damn it
six more weeks of Winter the ground
Punxsutawney Phil I gotta go guys I'd
love to stick around for another drink
but I gotta go you know that weather
prognosticating groundhog so I gotta get
to it man I gotta write this it's fair I
know it's February 1st but dude tomorrow
it's gonna come out tomorrow dude
just some guy sitting in Erie
Pennsylvania I gotta go dude I know you
want me to [__] drink another drink I
gotta go though and I gotta write this
article because if I don't then you know
who's gonna
they're gonna beat it we're not gonna
get the clicks
groundhog Club Handler
ajrim holds Punxsutawney Phil the
weather
I want to assassinate Punxsutawney Phil
dude
like he's a [__] politician
AJ darumi holds Punxsutawney Phil this
weather prognostic groundhog about
Pennsylvania stop saying that dude this
is the second time they said that
look at these people the crowd watches
the fireworks while waiting Punxsutawney
Phil the weather products are getting
grounded I mean dude
stop saying it
it's like he's the [__] wrestler
but they keep saying it dude
the crowd watches facilities waiting for
Punk star to kill the weather I swear to
God this article has said Punk's going
to feel the weather prognostic getting
groundhog
six times now no way the crap watcher
this is crazy
oh it's written by AI
that's right this is how we know that
it's [__] up because even this is how
we know how boring it is we got AI doing
it well you have adults with no shirts
on they wrote Phil on their chest
is there a worse name than Phil
it's the worst name
if I was married to someone and somebody
said hey I'm having a baby whoa boy or
girl boy yeah dude finally what you want
to name it and she said Phil
dude I go like I put my sunglasses on
and I go
I'm out dude with the [__]
and then just straight up wait whoops
wrong one God damn it didn't want that
one wanted this one just
with different women because I'm not I'm
done with that relationship what would
you want to name them Phil oh really
[Music]
that's it dude I'm done
I you know it's like oh oh dude you
wanna name a Phil Miles done dude I just
worst name Keith and Phil dude wow are
there brothers named Keith and Phil that
would be terrible how pasty white are
they
dude you ever seen a [__] tan guy
named Phil no Keith no way
no way and if you and if they are
they're muscular
dude I've never said anything more true
there are no pale keiths and Phil unless
they're a [__] Jack this [__] then
they're tan
he speaks the truth dude we talk about
the hard-hitting issues I don't like uh
how people talk about not hard-hitting
issues so
it is what it is let's do some uh dude I
didn't want to do I I thought I didn't
want to do this anymore uh Miss
connections do we have them
and I decided to because MGK said you
got to do them
when I ran into him he's like you got to
do more misconnection so I'm doing them
these are great these are from this
one's from downtown Los Angeles down on
LS DTS LS whatever that is
uh looking for my slim sweat friend
you know I am looking for my slim
feminine guy friend we met a bar we met
in a bar in DTLA area I was on top of
things okay we get it you know
you were such a all over smooth shaved
fried
okay friend I'm assuming it means and we
met occasionally and liked each other a
lot where are you
slowly sad here's another one what a
week
who's having one of those weeks
just so sad
been super
who's having one of those weeks been
super busy at work I just want to get
away for a bit wow do not contact me on
solicitors that's so vague what do you
mean do not contact you and solicit the
whole thing's just live uh need a man
around the house Los Angeles older woman
only ages 65 to 80.
weight
oh she's an older woman need a man
around the house that's 65 to 80.
dude what the [__] is he gonna do get a
young buck that can [__] move [__]
around and help what do you need a man
around the house for to die
need a man around the house
60 needs to be 65 to 80. love dying guys
here's another one looking for a girl
San Dimas looking for a female for a
good time free now until two at my
apartment can Uber you if you needed
let me know
a little smaller below there we go dude
the guy needs panuma nah but he's owning
it man
he's owning it but also he's hiding
behind the computer he needs to go out
to Town Square and be like I'm a little
smaller below let me know if anyone
wants to hang sup
um free now until two
at my apartment when did he you know
that means he did it this morning like
how lucky is this guy hoping to get
that's hilarious
um
do not contact me or something lost my
top truck guy well what's this all about
West Hollywood lost the Craigslist email
from last year wow this guy's really on
top of [__] you know
I'm the white grad student who used to
host you for Pipe Cleaning
hey guy just say it
I mean you don't even I know you get it
you'll get removed and flagged if you
say
instead of you know
but like you can be a little more closer
to what you're talking about than pipe
cleaning like we all we know what you
mean so just get closer to saying it
oh my God are you still around milkman
senuendo what color was your truck now
he's quizzing them okay
uh dude I feel like that these are uh
sad okay
they're all sad
and these guys need to get a hobby try
pickleball okay
I get it though loneliness is a tough
thing to deal with loneliness sucks
and sometimes you really want to find
your top truck guy
he's out there somewhere you ever see
everyone's got that one person right
where it's like oh [__] I wonder what
the [__] happened to that person I got
two
uh and then I got a few also dudes like
that non-sexual where it's like I wonder
what happened to that person
non-sect you know sometimes women you're
like I wonder what they're living I hope
they're living good
one time I I was like I wonder what
happened to that woman and uh she turned
out to be a [__] straight up
bodybuilder and I was like holy [__] I
[__] came across her one day and she
was like absolutely shredded and I was
like Jesus Christ
and then she has a shredded dude like a
pumped up dude like a dude that is
[__] Tana named Phil and uh which is
great great for her they live a happy
life they go to the gym so much and eat
so much chicken and uh and then uh
dudes are like that though dude like in
a non-sexual way you can think about a
dude and be like I wonder what happened
to that [__]
I used to know a guy Michael who was in
my high school and like what happened to
that guy he
he was super Russian his dad was super
Russian
um
whatever happened to Danny Vick
you know what I'm talking about
in my Elementary School Danny Vick was
the kind of guy he would wear a neon
green
uh
uh what do you call it tank tops
and one time I was like hey dude uh
because people were going through
puberty and I wasn't yet and I was like
show me your muscle and it goes like
this and I did it because I asked him to
show me his muscles because I wanted to
see if he had hair under his armpit yet
I was too insecure to ask him do you
have hair on your armpit yet I said show
me your muscle it goes like this and I
said oh cool and he said you just did
that because you want to see if I had
hair in my armpit huh
and I said no
and he said yeah you did and I said no I
didn't do it I just want to see your
muscle
how did he know but that's Danny Vick
for you New Jersey
Omar Pitts what happened to him
who are your guys like that think about
it and get back to me I don't care but
you know you know what I do care you
know what comment in the YouTube section
what in the comment section who are the
people that you by the way do it I have
[__] black nail polish okay I get it
dude I did it because my son wanted me
to do it and and Kristen put it on it
was a nice intimate moment she did it
showed my son he couldn't care less and
then I had it on there I put up videos
online where I'm on stage doing this
[__] you know my tick tocks are going
dummy viral and [__] and everyone's like
ah [__]
they got to you huh
the the black painted nails you would
roast somebody that I don't care so I
got the [__] black painted nails for
my son and and I tell you what I didn't
know about that they keep it nice though
now because I used to pick my cuticles
and now I don't I just pick the nails
and my fingernails dude they're healthy
as [__] dude
and we love it so uh yeah
anyway dude I'm not gonna do it again
probably but if I have these fingernails
paints on for New York shows
by that time I lost the plot
um all right so that's it thank you very
much for listening to the show we are
super good subscribe and like the
channel we love it leave comments uh
really appreciate you guys and
um
go to chrysalia.com to get tickets I'll
be in Kansas City I'll be in uh
different places I'll be in Midland I'll
be in uh a bunch of different spots New
York I'll be there February 18th Rhode
Island uh love you guys Tulsa I'll be in
you know different places so all right
that's it for YouTube uh that is it for
YouTube
um and if you want to support our
patreon for the longer episodes the
uncut episodes the ones with no ads uh
then we can uh you can do that and it
would really be awesome for us to help
support the show it keeps the show going
six dollars that's it and uh you get all
the backlog episodes of the patreon
episodes because there are patreon
episodes once a month and you'll get
like there's 22 of them for six bucks
you get them bam just like that so
thanks a lot
thank you
[Music]
foreign